[ __ ] bosses pissed me off bosses get  employees and as if like they're there  to serve them it's [ __ ] crazy the  entitlement by small business owners and  managers is obnoxious these are fellow  human beings you have people that own  companies that I expect my people to  work the way I work I'm like are you  giving them the same money the [ __ ] are  you talking about I've never even  remotely crossed my mind in my 25 years  that anyone should even work as hard as  me they work for me I work for them but  I'm getting different economics of  course they should not work like the  delusion  biggest mistake people make and why they  can't build scalable businesses is they  have selfish expectations of their  employees  [Music]